[Music]
delight always a delight to see you it's
a delight to see you it's truly a
delight to see yes you're not like
anyone else I know in so many glorious
ways well you to your unique you're a
truly unique yes you know that I like to
examine you what happened here what
happened here are you talking about your
thumbnail there okay I guess it's your
show and you're asking the questions I
uh I've had a cracked thumbnail for many
many years it's just cracked I'll get in
there close life I never noticed that I
just it's tough we finally found a flaw
in Conan I suppose look look what I have
we we're in common I love that you threw
your glasses let me try those out these
are very Jeff Goldblum II glasses
when you put him on it just looks like
you should be saying I'm gonna tell the
Dean I'll tell the Dean on you guys
there's no deer in this storm my god I
love that you're so good so good look at
that look at that whoa I was looking at
the bottom of your shoe why because you
notice strange things you're looking at
thumbnails the bottom of a shoe I'm like
Sherlock Holmes in many ways have you
solved any crimes ever on Law & Order
you have yes no that's right yeah I
couldn't do that I really couldn't do
that can you imagine those guys are
fantastic they really are but let's talk
about the bottom of shoes why do you
notice the bottom of shoes well I like
them I have a lovely shoe shoe repair
bra you're very throwing your glasses at
what am I gonna do if I'm not using this
pen right
you you know I tell my girlfriend Emily
Livingston I say don't break my glasses
she thinks I'm kind of nerdy too I think
but I go don't break my glasses don't
break my glasses she was in the Olympics
Emily Liberty shoes in the Olympic Park
while you were saying
[Applause]
it was pride coming I'd coming out the
gracious thing would have been to let it
go unnoticed here on the wrong show for
that yeah but the very talented thing
would be to yes these are a moment
something we've it like you do into a
beautiful web of comedy remember you're
my favorite you bring it out in me I I
act like I think you see me yes yes
cartoon character when you're here I do
something everywhere I Drive in LA
everywhere I see these ads for this this
guy's about that I'm like horse manure
I'm all over the place literally spread
around me down soon they'll be done soon
no I delight seeing you're like the cat
that ate the canary in this photo
they're everywhere in Los Angeles and
everywhere I Drive I see that photo and
I see you seem to be like is you Conan
that kind of I see you speeding code do
speed you're you're careful when you
drive
I always obey the law I'm very careful
these days driving I think it's very I'm
frightened of having anything bad happen
Emily got into a little accident that I
was very obsessed here full name in
birth come on she but oh yeah I'm great
you know what I do these days not only
do I not text which I recommend for
everybody but I I'm loath to put on the
radio these days or do anything I like
to really pay attention at every single
moment I really do it's the Zen of
driving well you shouldn't be looking
that way if
maybe you were texting there's an owl
behind me oh hello mr. owl ha that's
scary
how about hop out dumb what's scary what
would scared you that well that big that
to that huge globe look at that that's
the moon yeah but I've never seen it
that close we've seen the moon not that
close that strange orb in the sky
shocked me